it feels like half of glasgow has
arrived in seville it is quite the
atmosphere building up towards this
europa league final against eintracht
frankfurt a hundred thousand rangers
fans officially have come in it feels
like there's a lot more out here in the
heat of the afternoon in the spanish
sunshine and they are certainly getting
into it lots of sombreros and of course
they've had those reminders from legends
at rangers football club over the course
of this week that they've got to come
and enjoy this moment and enjoy it in
the right way a lot of people still
looking for tickets in the build-up to
kick off later tonight and that demand
is because it's quite a relatively small
stadium only 40 000 or so capacity
tonight so there's a second stadium in
the city that's been open for fans
without tickets to the game so they can
watch it on big screens and if they've
got a ticket the rangers fans here well
they are just feeling like they're on
cloud nine it's a carnival
tonight yeah absolutely
honestly it's the biggest game ever
live lives honestly yes it's like
unbelievable isn't it we can't believe
we're here and it's just over this world
isn't it it's the best experience of our
lives isn't it fantastic not tickets no
no so well i'll just stick together
we're going over to the
stadium just outside and we'll be in
there for the night so we're happy just
to be here it's the the times that we've
all went through it's just crazy um
going down to the third division and
then we're here you know nine ten years
later so i think it makes it a bit more
special
we've been speaking to some rangers fans
who said really we've got no right to be
here considering the decade that we have
had just 10 years ago they went into
administration they were liquidated and
then forced to start from scratch in the
third division the fourth flight of
scottish football they've built their
way back and are now back where all
these fans believe that they belong of
course lots of jibes going to and fro
with celtic fans back home they won the
league this season but rangers are here
they said they wouldn't swap this for
anything